I'm very excited to be at the World
Economic Forum at Davos this year with
my Carnegie Mellon contingent where the
word on everyone's lips is education my
work is in educational technology where
we use the most advanced interactive and
intelligent machines in order to improve
education online education is all the
rage right now but what we're finding is
that the data you can get from these
systems is really impoverished with
respect to what people actually do in
order to learn and so if we could
harness the power of the real physical
classroom and collect the same sorts of
data or even better we have a real
chance and improving education worldwide
the data that we're collecting lets us
look at who's speaking in the classroom
when they're speaking are all of the
students getting a chance to participate
what's the teachers speaking style and
are they allowing everyone to
collaborate or challenge each other's
ideas Carnegie Mellon has been a
longtime leader in understanding both
how humans learn but also how we can
apply technologies to improve that even
further